In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 19th, on which we commemorate, are venerable
and God-bearing Father, Paesius the Great.
The youngest of a family of seven, St. Paesius was consecrated to God by his mother after
a vision of an angel.
Reaching the threshold of adulthood, he went off to the nitrogen desert to be with Abba Pumbu,
who clothed him in the monastic habit.
Perfectly obedient to his spiritual father as to God himself, he made rapid progress
on the path of asceticism.
As Pumbu, to test him, had told him to keep his head bowed without ever looking anyone
in the face, Paesius spent three years with his gaze fixed on the ground and his spirit
entirely plunged in prayer, pondering on the words of Holy Scripture which became in
his throat sweeter than honey.
After Abba Pumbu's death, he lived with St. John Colobos in the same cell, sharing with
him the same spiritual aspirations and the same way of ascetic life.
However, after some time, Paesius, yearning towards a higher perfection, began to fast
the whole week, only eating bread and salt on Saturdays.
He then extended his fast to two weeks and was seized with an impetuous desire to be alone
with God.
An angel appeared to them and told John to stay where he was, to guide those who came
to him on the path of virtue, and prescribed for Paesius that he withdraw to the western
part of the desert of Settis.
Arriving at the spot indicated by the angel, Paesius dug a cave in the rock and devoted
himself to prayer with such zeal that Christ frequently appeared to him to testify to his
favor and to predict that this desert would soon be filled with Settis come to imitate
his way of life.
He promised that he would look after their material needs, protecting them from the devil's
sin.
Paesius valiantly resisted all temptations, and when a wealthy Egyptian came to offer him
a large sum of money, the ascetic, having discerned that this was a case of a snare set by the
devil to make him lose the grace of evangelical poverty, repulsed him without hesitation.
During an ecstasy, in the course of which he was transported to Paradise, in the bosom of
the church of the first born, he received the grace to dispense completely with food,
and to live only on the holy communion that he received on Sundays.
He spent seventy years in this way to the end of his days, without feeling hunger, for divine
grace came and strengthened him.
The rays of his holiness spread far and wide, and monks and layfolk came in great numbers
asking to join him, like bees gathering in a hive to enjoy the spiritual honey of his teaching.
With sovereign wisdom, the saint let some immediately embrace the hermit life, and recommended
to others to live in community, in submission and obedience, each according to his capacity
He gave to everyone, however, as an absolute commandment never to do anything by his own will,
but in all things to act according to the orders of his spiritual father.
Having delivered his teaching to his first disciples, he went for three years to a cave in the depths
of the desert, and there nodded his long hair to a stake high up, so that he was forced
to remain standing.
In response to this further violence to nature, Christ appeared to him in all his glory,
and promised him to forgive every sinner for whom his servant interceded.
It was thus that shortly afterwards, Paesios was able to deliver from hell the soul of a
negligent monk, for whom his spiritual father had come to beg the prayers of the man of God.
Although he strove to withdraw further and further from men, God ordained that he returned
to the outer desert, nitria, to teach the brethren, and promising him a double reward, he said
to him, he who practices asceticism in solitude is my servant, just as he who puts himself at
the service of others to teach them is my son and heir.
When the monks of nitria heard that Paesios had come among them, they hastened to welcome
him. Among them was St. John Colobos, his former companion who knocking on the door of his
cell heard Paesios talking with a mysterious person, and it was a great surprise to him when
he went in to find that the elder was alone.
Paesios revealed to him that it had been St. Constantine the Great, who had been sent to him by God
to testify to his admiration for the monks and to swear to him that he himself in heaven had
not acquired such glory and familiarity with God. And the emperor had added that he regretted not
having abandoned the purple for the simple clothing of the monk.
Ava Poeman, then still young, also came to visit the man of God, in company with St. Paul of
Thebes, who was a friend of Paesios, but seized by fear, he did not dare to cross the threshold,
discerning that he had stayed outside, St. Paesios made him come in, embraced him tenderly,
and predicted that he would be a lampstand in the desert and the means of salvation for many.
While St. Paesios was living in solitude, his disciples had formed around him a sort of community of
hermits. Experienced in spiritual warfare, he set right their illusions, exhorted them to repentance
and helped them discern between temptations from demons and bad thoughts suggested by their own
passions. By his prayers, one day he even bound the demon and stopped attempting the brethren who
were too feeble to engage in conflict with it. On another occasion, under the threat from the saint,
the evil one confessed that he did not attack beginners because divine grace and their zeal
protected them. But patiently awaited the time when they began to give in to negligence and to
make them fall with ease into his net. When he was asked which is the greatest of the virtues,
the elder replied, that which is done in secret. And to another brother who had asked him the same
question, he said, the greatest of the virtues is to follow the counsel of another and not one's own will.
As for him, as soon as he found himself in the midst of the brethren, he let nothing be known about
his way of life, and if one of his ascetic practices became known, he abandoned it at once,
to escape the praise of men. One day when he was praying in his cell,
Christ appeared to him in company with two angels, and imitating Abraham, the patriarch,
Saint Paisios washed his feet. The Lord then blessed him and said, peace be with you, my chosen servant.
When one of his disciples had refused to drink the water that had been used to wash the Lord's feet,
the saint sent him to the burial place of the three holy men who had been endowed with the gift of
prophecy, and one of them rose from the dead to exhort him to unmermering obedience. The disciple then
bitterly repented for his disobedience that had deprived him of great grace.
Reaching an advanced age, Paisios went to visit Abba Paul, and they spent some time together. Paisios
exhorted the other old men as though he were a young beginner, that they should compete in zeal
to rise unceasingly Godward in prayer, as the Lord gave them strength.
Then, on returning to his desert, he fell asleep in peace, entering the abode of the blessed shortly
before Saint Paul. It is said that Abba Isador, having learned of his death, went to take the relics
of Saint Paisios to translate them to Pesidia. When the ship carrying them drew near to the place where
Saint Paul was buried, it stopped. A hermit, with the gift of insight, explained that it was a sign
from God that they must also take Saint Paul's body on board. Thus, reunited in body, after death,
the two saints were placed in a monastery in Pesidia, where they worked many miracles.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.